I'm very excited to share with you today
the first of what I hope could be many
Charisma on Command podcasts. For our
first ever guests, we have Dr. K from
HealthyGamer.GG. He's a mental health
expert, someone I've learned a
tremendous amount from. And we have Joe
Hudson, who is an executive leadership
coach at OpenAI and founder of Art of
Accomplishment. Both of these guys have
taught me a ton, and I'm so excited to
share with you today. We go at the
surface level, we touch on some of the
charismatic tactics, but really this
conversation is about the deep essence
of charisma. What is it at its core, and
how can you unleash it in yourself? Hope
that you enjoy.
Joe, Alloke, wonderful to have both of
you guys here.
I'm thrilled to be here, man. This is
like super exciting. Thank you guys.
Thank you guys.
So, I've spent 20 years trying to figure
out charisma, and there's only a few
people that I would genuinely ask this
question to. So, I'm I'm very excited to
do it. How is it that you guys
understand charisma? Do you see it
primarily as behaviors, mindsets,
something else?
You want to kick things off?
Yeah.
Um
I I make a distinction when I think
about charisma is there's two forms of
charisma. There's the form of charisma
that is
I have learned a set of behaviors that
allow people to
um like me, be convinced by me.
I think uh
typically that's I would call it like a
slimy form of charisma. Okay. Um and and
the thing about it the notable thing
about it is that it
it doesn't last very long. Like that
kind of charisma can
can hold in a relationship for you know,
maybe three to six months, and then at
best maybe just the the length of a car
sales, you know, like some somewhere in
there.
And then there's the a form of charisma
that is
just basically uh I would call it auth-
authenticity and aliveness.
Where there's somebody who is so deeply
on their purpose being themselves and
full of aliveness where they're not
restricting parts of themselves and then
that's an incredibly
something that draws people in deeply.
Mhm. I think the
the first one comes because you want
something like power. You want people to
like you, you want people to love you,
you're trying to fill a hole.
The other one comes because you have
learned how to love yourself in all
aspects of yourself.
And so that that's how I think about it.
I don't think about it as one thing in
modern society. I think about it as two.
I I think the first part of my journey
was very much what you might describe as
the slimy form. But do you have a
similar understanding of it? Do you see
it as
Yeah, so one thing I love about Joe is
that it blows my mind how he understands
so much about the things that I have
formally trained in. Mhm.
So like the way I'd answer that
question, so two or three different
things. So I I tried to understand this
myself like what is charisma?
So the first thing that I sort of
realized from psychiatric training is
that we think about charisma as if it's
within you, right? Like charisma is an
attribute of a person. But fundamentally
how do you if you're on a desert island
by yourself, can you be charismatic?
Mhm. Yeah. And so the first thing to
understand that I think most people miss
is that charisma is a dyadic
interaction. It is about a response of
something that you do that happens in
the other person. So no mastery of
charisma will be complete until you
recognize that there is
something in the other person that needs
to be activated. Mhm. Now the question
becomes how do you go about activating
it?
So this is where I think there's several
layers to it, right? So we have like you
know, uh and this is what's so
fascinating about the research on
charisma is it's so multi-disciplinary.
You have studies from leadership,
management, business, like Harvard
Business School kind of stuff. Then you
have stuff about basic psychology, you
have stuff about neuroscience, and then
you even have um
charisma research from anthropology and
history.
So, people will look at like
people like Rasputin and try to ask
themselves,
how was this person so charismatic,
right? And which what cuz like he kind
of has this bad reputation, but is that
sleazy? But it absolutely withstood the
test of time.
So, I think that the way I think about
charisma is in like all of those
dimensions. And when I work with people,
it's like working on, okay, let's
understand what are the variables that
make a leadership successful?
How do you cultivate those on a personal
from a personal standpoint? What's going
on in the brain? And then how do you
connect to this deeper kind of charisma
that like Joe is talking about, right?
That is not about the other person that
really comes and flows from within you.
Wow. Love both of those. Is it Go ahead.
Yeah, to geek out a little bit more,
there's
there's another interesting thing about
charisma, people thinking they don't
have it or they do have it. So,
just as like a internal experiment, most
humans have a
critical voice in their head, repetitive
negative self-talk.
That part of you is super charismatic
for most people for the beginning of
their life. Meaning, that most people
listen to that and they're like, yeah,
uh-huh, I'm on Yes. Yes, I should lose
weight. Yes, yes, I I should be a nicer
person. Yeah, I da da da. So, there's a
relationship that we have with ourselves
where there is some part of us that we
are in a charismatic relationship with.
And so, that's a really interesting
thing to think about when someone's
saying, oh, I want to be charismatic,
there's an interesting thought process
of like, well, what's the part of you
that is charismatic? And what's the part
of you that's just following along
going, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, listening
to it. So, it's an it's an interesting
it's an interesting thing to see that
there is that charismatic nature in all
of us. Yeah.
And that's a very direct experience of
being able to see it.
I feel like I've noticed that growing up
that
the things that you're you're a middle
schooler, and the thing that make the
girl like you is ignoring her
and running away from her and teasing
her being mean to her. And so I as I
look back, it's I wonder if that's a
projection of like the things that are
charismatic early in our life are the
parts of ourselves that are
not forthcoming and open and kind to
ourselves. And
for me I see that some of those early
behaviors that I learned were like if
somebody asks you to do them a favor,
make sure that it you don't just do it
and roll over like you're you know,
you're you work for them or something
like that. And so I'm curious is is
there stages where it looks tends to
look different interation inter-
interactively between different people
based on life stage or how should people
even go about learning this if it's a
something that has so many different
ways of being expressed and uh types of
it almost.
Yeah, so I I think um the way that I
would I approach this is like let's look
at like the basic research. Like what is
the best body of research that tells us
what charisma is?
The problem with that kind of research
is if you say like authenticity, which
is a huge part of the charisma equation,
telling you what charisma is is not the
same as developing it, right? One is
like what it is. Like so like how do you
be successful in right life? You You can
You can ask someone that question and
they can say be rich. Mhm. That doesn't
give you like a method. So so kind of my
approach is what are the things that
actually contribute to charisma, and
then what is the mechanism of attaining
those things?
Mhm. So my understanding of it is like a
couple of big variables float to the
surface. The first is having a vision.
Mhm. So if you sort of think about like
who in your life is charismatic, they
have an idea of where they're going.
That's like a very huge thing. Second
thing is um the ability to deal with
setbacks with some degree of like
equanimity and resilience. So when we
think about and this is mostly from like
the leadership research, we think about
what makes a leader, it's like when
thing go when when things go bad, who do
you turn to? Right? Who can handle
problems? And that's where like the
vision and the ability to
be resilient and deal with setbacks is
huge. Um the third really really
concrete thing is
uh good with words.
So, this is where we go like a little
bit, you know, theoretical for a second,
but how do we know whether a human being
is competent or not? So, competency in
most human beings comes from like their
mind, right? So, the way that they
think. Like if we look at like the what
separates human beings from animals,
it's our mind. And what it how does one
human being understand the quality of
another human being's mind?
And that is through speech, usually.
Mhm. So, this is why like in the field
of psychiatry, we had Freud who's trying
to figure out what is going on in
someone's mind, and what does he do? He
listens to them.
So, how do you know about the people in
your life? How do you change the minds
of of the people that you work with? Um
you know, you use the power of speech
and you use your ears. So, it's
basically like some degree of
authenticity, and that's the fourth one.
So, authenticity, vision, the ability to
deal with setbacks without getting like
destroyed, and then being articulate
with your words.
Those are like the four biggest
variables. And then there's a couple of
variables that are really weird that are
also pretty big, but I think we'll get
to those later. Sure.
It's a that's
I love that breakdown. It The two things
that come to mind when I hear it the the
the first one is that there's a study
that was done, gosh, I think it was like
in the '90s or something, where they had
people come up and speak in front of
groups, and then they all said how
intelligent they were.
And they did not track their
intelligence well, they tracked how well
they spoke. So, basically, if you speak
well, we think you're intelligent, even
though that may not be the case at all.
They're not actually correlated.
Wow. they're not highly correlated. So
So that that's one thing that's really
interesting. So there is an articulation
that especially in the short term really
helps you
convince people that
you're
you should be somebody should be
followed or somebody who's smart. The
other piece that came to mind as you
were speaking about this is that I I
don't know any research on this, but I
just know the practicality of it, which
is
people
often are found charismatic by the way
they listen.
And I don't know where that is in the in
the research, but meaning
I think there's like something famous
where there was
Miss Roosevelt or something like that
had two prime ministers of England this
story that you've heard about and one
was like he was the smartest man in the
world and the other prime minister
said to her she said about him, I felt
like I was the smartest woman in the
world. What I notice is that
just listening in the way that you
listen and how open-hearted you're
listening and how accepting you are and
the questions you ask often
is like a very charismatic
both in leadership and and otherwise and
I think it's a missed part cuz we're
usually going I'm going to go into a
meeting how am I going to say the thing
that I want to say. We're not saying, oh
I'm going in the meeting how am I going
to listen?
But the way that you listen actually has
as much if not more power what you get
out of that meeting and what people
think of you.
Is that age dependent? Cuz you said
people miss this. I didn't make a video
on listening for about six years.
Right? And I would say I still had a
magnetism to people. So I was very
focused on what I was saying, how people
understand what I was saying.
As I get older
I notice that shift. Is that something
that
is age or stage dependent as people get
into it? What do you think of that? Cuz
it seems like such a glaring omission,
but at the time, it didn't seem like a
glaring omission.
I mean I I I don't think it's
age-dependent dependent. I do think it
is in a sense stage-dependent. Okay.
Right? So, I think if we if we talk
about, you know, I I love Joe's like
very practical framework of like there's
the sleazy kind and then there's like
this deep thing. And the other variable
that I was alluding to, by the way, is
one study looked at very charismatic
people and basically found a variable
which is like divinity. Mhm. So, if you
look at like Joan of Arc and Jesus and
the Buddha and Rasputin, some of the
most charismatic people in the history
of humanity are like spiritual people.
Mhm. So, I I think that if we sort of
look at like some of these surface-level
things and I think listening is a great
example of something that cuts across
the research. Right? So, there's a a
there's a a certain amount of
authenticity that is related to empathy,
that is related to listening. When you
truly listen to people,
what you articulate back to them, right,
sounds so intelligent. So, I think like
listening is this beautiful kind of like
thing that that allow it's kind of like
an
lets you
check a lot of boxes. Mhm. And I think
basically you can start with some of
these like skill kind of things, but I
think the real charisma, like this
transformative world-shaping charisma,
which each and every one of us have, in
order to unearth that, like I think
listening is is one step along that
process. And there's a there's a very
interesting mechanism which we can get
into, but I think
we'll get into that when we get there.
Yeah. Yeah, let's talk about unearthing
it. It I think I think as far as your
stages go, I what I notice is that
listening doesn't happen until you stop
having something to prove.
So, Yeah, yeah, yeah.
So, that that's that I think and which
is again
being in love with yourself or accepting
yourself. The more you're accepting
yourself, then these other things
unravel Mhm. in you.
Good. I feel like I have a really cuz
I've been trying to understand the way
that you guys said in my own I feel like
I have a good sense of it. So what is
this process for unearthing it for
developing these vision the ability
speak articulate to listen well. How
would you guys advise people to go about
taking their first steps assuming that
they're my audience is often like
from young 20s to upper 30s if that's
that typical stage of life. So I think
maybe what I can do is talk about the
four variables that I mentioned and then
I think the real conversation is going
to be getting to that true charisma and
so I kind of want to like finish that
off and get into this discussion of
loving yourself which is still confusing
to me by the way so I want to hear what
you have to say. Right so the first
thing is a vision so I think a lot of
people if you look at like their
direction in life like they sort of
don't have a direction. So we're we're
in a society where our senses our senses
are bombarded by what we should do.
There's like Instagram influencers and
like YouTubers and like everyone's like
telling you what you should do what you
should be. Social media has an effect on
our ego which is very bad right so it
makes us self-conscious it makes us more
depressed it makes us more anxious. So
literally what these algorithms have
figured out how to do is make you feel
bad about yourself and then sell you an
answer. The problem is that there's a
thousand answers for everything that you
feel bad about.
So the the first thing is that's there's
no vision there right there's no
unifying thing you're always trying to
solve a problem. Love the way that Joe
put it you're trying to fix something
within yourself. But that's not a vision
for your life that's trying to like fix
this today and fix this tomorrow. So you
kind of have to do some internal work
which I think we're going to get to and
really develop like what you want from
your life and the only way you're going
to find that is from you and then once
you have a path once you have a plan
then people will like literally
gravitate towards you because you're one
of the few people who seems like they've
got a clue because everyone we have a
loneliness epidemic we have a mental
health epidemic. You know, so that then
the moment that you become this thing
people just start like showing up.
So that's I think a big part of that
vision.
I think articulation is really
actually simple. So what I strongly
recommend people do is anything that
you're going to talk about you write
first.
So there are a couple of cool
neuroscience mechanisms there where
when you write the first thing that it
does is it slows down the speed of your
thoughts which helps them like gel a
little bit more. You think faster than
you speak. So a big part of speaking
well is like slowing down your thoughts.
The other really cool thing about
writing is when you write something it
activates your sensory input, right? Cuz
you're reading what you're writing. And
the moment you activate your sensory
input, whatever you're writing sinks
into your brain and you learn it.
Now once you know something
then when you open your mouth it sounds
really good.
Right? So like how do you become more
articulate? You literally write it out.
And one thing that I didn't really
appreciate so I tried to write a book on
video game addiction and it sucked. But
then the first time I started streaming
the words came out like really fluidly
because I had written this 300-page
awful book. But in the process of
writing it clarified my thoughts.
So that's vision, that's articulation.
I'm sure we'll get to like setbacks and
equanimity and things like that because
I think that's going to be kind of like
ego related. So I think those are like
two or three really like two really big
things that people can start with and
then I think there's this deeper work
which will sort of make things I'm sure
like easier as we move on.
Yeah.
The only thing I would add there is
if I remember the research correctly I
think the writing things out is probably
going to work for 70% of the people and
so
so if you're one of those people who've
done that and it doesn't work, then
you're probably an auditory processor
and so you could probably do it by
speaking it out over like multiple
times. So it's it's depending but most
people are writers, yeah.
Yeah and I I love the phrase some people
think in order to talk and some people
talk in order to think. Yeah yeah
exactly. Yeah I'm I'm that auditory
person which is why I remember I was
sitting at a
uh when I was doing a non-profit work uh
uh helping run this um
this foundation and I was in a meeting
in Cleveland, Ohio and uh
and this woman just walks up to me. She
goes, "Oh, you don't read, do you?
You're you're an auditory processor." I
was like, "How did you know?" And she
and she described all my behaviors that
that let her know that I was
um
so as far as I would say that those are
like amazing practical steps. The The
number one thing that I think
to do is really deeply inquire as to
what makes it that you want to have
charisma.
To really understand that about
yourself.
So typically the way that it works is
once I have this, then I can be lovable.
Once I have this, then I can be good
enough. Once I have this, then I will be
happy.
And that's the that's the ultimate
con that that that that that we tell
ourselves.
And so to recognize that there's nothing
that you actually have to do to to love
yourself or to be loved. And there's you
don't have to create a certain amount of
value to be So questioning the problem
itself, questioning the the premise I
think is a really good first step for
the other things that that you know, the
the deeper authenticity part of it.
Because that's going to teach you
exactly the places that you're not
accepting yourself. Mhm. If you start
looking at what you're telling yourself
you have to do to be good enough or
lovable or not abandoned or whatever,
that's the places that you're going to
be able to go in and say, "Oh, these are
the parts that are unloved. This is
where I start my work." Hey guys,
cutting in here from the future. You may
be asking yourself, "How do I implement
this stuff concretely in my life?" And I
want to offer you two options. The first
you've heard from me before, it's my
course Charisma University. If you're
someone who is focused on how do I get
more dates, how do I get a promotion,
how do I become a leader in my friend
group, and just generally feel more
confident, those are all results that
our students have gotten time and time
again. It's a 30-day course within three
to five days you should be three to five
days you should be seeing massive
results. If that's something that you're
looking for, check out Charisma
University. It's the fastest way I know
to knock that area of your life out of
the park. The second option is if you're
looking more for this state of charisma
that we've been talking about in the
conversation. And that would be Joe's
Connection Course. I've gone through it
myself, it's tremendously powerful, and
I can't recommend it enough. So, I asked
The Art of Accomplishment team if they
could do a deal for Charisma on Command
listeners, and they set up an affiliate
link that will actually get you 30% off.
It's a cohort-based course, so you can't
do it on your own time, you're going
through it with a group of people. And
if you're watching this at launch, the
next cohort comes out in September, but
you can join the waitlist and use our
code to get 30% off whenever you do sign
up for it. So, both of those are
excellent. You know I don't advertise
other people's courses often. I really
think this one is great. I'll leave you
with that as two options, and we'll hop
right back into the show. When I look
back, if I say, "Okay, what might I have
asked myself as like I need a girlfriend
or I need a Right. this this particular
guy needs to like me or something like
that." What would be the practical
walk-through of, "Okay, so my my initial
answer is
I that girl has to like me in order for
me to like myself. Then then what?" And
so, what I took is, "Okay, I'm going to
make her like me." Right. Right. Right.
I know what to do now.
I'd figure out what she likes, you know,
be all of be all the things that she
likes. So, Charlie, when you did that,
what happened next? Yeah, exactly. So,
I said So, what I started doing was
watching uh very carefully. What is she
responding to? What are women in general
responding to? They like guys who play
guitar. I learned to play the guitar.
You know, right? So, so just run that
process for about 10 years and now I'm
doing jujitsu, learning multiple
languages, like trying to be the
renaissance man that I can, which is
effective in a way. And there was
wonderful secondary, tertiary effects of
I love music and I got to do that. And I
didn't at that beginning stage get to
the the self-love and the
self-acceptance. So, I'm curious
how someone might run through that in a
way that as that is cleaner than than
what I did perhaps.
Hold on a second.
Go ahead. Go ahead.
I'm assuming I think we're going the
same place.
It's like and then you got the woman,
but it didn't Right, so that's what I
exactly what I want to hear about. So,
don't fast forward to 10 years when you
started doing the deeper work. I want to
know one year in, right? So, let's let
everyone who's listening to this is like
Oh, but I think we need to hear
Sure.
when you started getting in shape, when
you started playing guitar, when you
started making money, two years in,
three years in. You did get the girl,
Charlie. Yeah. What happened then?
Girls. Girls, I'm assuming.
Yeah, yeah. No, it at first it was oh
god, I'll just
Uh at first I felt like king of the
universe. It was the greatest, most
thrilling, excited thing that I could
ever imagine. I didn't understand why
everyone in the world wasn't quitting
their job to go out to bars and flirt
and receive validation. It made no sense
to me. And uh when I saw,
you know, the occasional 40 or
45-year-old at the bar, I was like, that
guy gets it. Like,
that guy, he gets it. Um got
girlfriends, had casual encounters, and
then, you know, the the one that I
definitely had to have after years of
didn't get that girl in high school,
didn't get that girl in college.
But I was 27 and I finally got that one
that I had to have.
Did
have a intense period of just wanting
her to really like me as much as
possible that lasted many, many months.
Um
And then it became like the biggest ache
in my life. This like trying to make
this relationship work in a way that
felt good for me and for her was I was
still seeking like I was like I still
want to be in a non-monogamous open
relationship cuz I need all the
attention from multiple women, but I
have to please you as well, and I want
you to like me. And I, as I reflect back
on it, I understood my own happiness to
be
how much smiles, applause, and needing
is being directed at me from
my primary partner and other women that
I was casually seeing. Um and then my
hair started falling out, and
you know, like
So, you you know, and and I'm going to
tease you see this up I assume and you
can spike it over the net, Joe, cuz I
I'm pretty sure we're going to go the
same place, but like you know, so this
is what I see, and it's so challenging
cuz sometimes people will come to me,
and they they come to me, and they like
want to be better.
Mhm. Right? They want to be accepted.
They want to be loved. And then they
think like, okay, like clearly people
respect
dudes who are ripped, dudes who are
rich. Let me be that so I get their
respect. And then they fall into a very
dangerous trap, which is that they
succeed.
Mhm. And then there's this other really
this huge problem arises, which is like
basically unsolvable.
Now, you love this girl, you're into
her, you're crushing on your on on her,
you hate yourself for it. And you feel
powerless, but you want her so bad. So,
you do everything that you're supposed
to do, and then she says yes.
Mhm. And then when you go home, you're
wondering who is she in love with? Who
did she say yes to? Did she say yes to
this crafted version, but what about the
loser that I was before? What if I ever
become that again? What if I start
losing my hair or I start making less
money? So now what you've managed to do
is get exactly what you want, but it's
like a house of cards that could get
wiped away at any time. There's this
really scary like fear of abandonment
because you haven't been accepted.
Mhm. Your money has been accepted. Your
appearance has been accepted. You know,
and and so like it it's so scary and
doing that work, the deeper work, is
like it's such a common pattern where
I'm going to succeed and then I will get
what I want and it really messes me up
even more. Mhm.
Yeah, there's so many things I could say
about it.
The the my pithy phrase on this is um
the problem of becoming somebody to be
loved is that you never get loved.
The person that you were pretending to
be is the one that gets loved and so it
it never fulfills and that's like the
basically what
what was just said, but the secondary
part is that
there's a way to look at that that says,
"Oh, so glad that didn't work out cuz
now I can actually do the real work." It
seems to me that there's
often times this necessary step. For me
it wasn't about looks or money, for me
it was about awakening and spiritual
fulfillment. But oh, once I get to this
place then
and then when you get to that place and
there there's no there there, it's this
amazing thing because then you have to
reflect and say, "Oh, what is it
actually?" And then so
so there's a there's a part of human
development which is you don't want
people to walk before they can crawl.
There's a whole bunch of neurological
issues that come from that.
And so if if that's where you've got to
go to figure out that it's completely
unfulfilling, you know, feel free to go
there. It seemed apparently I needed to
do it and I'm sure there's ways Yeah, I
needed to do it, too. And I I think
actually many people do. Yeah, exactly.
Right. So so many people need to walk to
the end of the road to realize that this
is not working. Yeah.
Yeah, exactly.
And and then
there's a
there's a some people get lost there
because they don't they just can't
imagine that there's something other way
to do it because there's no examples of
another way to do it. And so if you find
yourself in that place
then it's back to how do you love
yourself? How do you love
get acceptance for who you are? And and
and what I mean who you are I mean all
the aspects of yourself.
Mhm. What I notice is and a and a good
way to measure it is that
the more that
I love every aspect of myself, the more
I can love everybody. Mhm. So if I'm in
the world not being able to love
somebody, that's clearly a pointer of
where I'm not accepting myself. Mhm.
When I get triggered, that's a clearly a
pointer where I'm not accepting myself.
And so
so that's where that that's when that
work starts coming into play.
So let me let me ask a question that I
know I would have had at 27 because it's
the first leap of improvements in my
life came from seemingly not accepting
myself. There was all of this advice
when I was 13, 14, 15, just be yourself,
just be yourself. And like that wasn't
going well for me at the time. Yeah. And
so I developed this philosophy of I'm
not going to be myself, I'm going to
choose myself. I'm going to decide how I
want to come across, how I want to be,
and I'm going to select that and
habituate certain behaviors and ways of
being. And my conception of myself was
this chooseable
thing that there was no essential it was
completely choice bound. So I'm
wondering
if I'd heard you say you have to accept
yourself at 27, I would have
I that I would have bit back hard.
to. Okay.
And great cuz I would have heard it that
way for sure. Yeah. That's why you're
doing that's why the 27 year old needs
to do all that stuff because everything
is a should and a have to and a
otherwise like there's this
the the the self relationship is one of
force.
So what is the self if not this
collection of chosen behaviors that I
accept?
I let's not go into that.
Yeah, I agreed. I I think we've got one
major step before we can get there.
hit it. So so you know it's maybe I I
can we'll we'll get there. Yeah, yeah,
yeah.
So so you know it's interesting cuz I
hear this a lot like especially in like
dating cuz dating is really hard right
now and people are like, "Oh, you know,
just be yourself." I think that's
terrible advice.
So I I I think if we
I think the worst thing you can be is
yourself.
I I know.
Yeah, I know. Yeah. We don't I'm so
looking forward to what cuz I know you
get it. So
I think the twist that you're about to
do I just cannot wait.
So so exactly, right? So and I think
this is going to give us the layer that
we're missing.
Okay.
So when someone says Okay, so let me ask
y'all, right? So when someone says, "I
should be myself." What do you think
that means to them?
To me I could tell you what it meant. I
should be shy, reserved,
withdrawn, like my video games, um
and not effective in my communication
with people and have the same small
group of friends that I do and not more
than that.
Right. So I I think when we when most
people say like, you know, like I I hear
all these things like, "If you can't
handle me at my worst, you don't deserve
me at my best." Which in a relationship
is a license to continue to be an
[__]
So I think most people live this life
where they have all of these internal
tendencies.
And what they think and then they fight
against those internal tendencies. So I
feel like being an ass, but I need to be
nice. So there's like this internal
tension.
And they they think, "Okay, like I
should be nice so like this is the the
part of me that I'm going to project.
That doesn't work, right? And so instead
what I should do is the layer underneath
like all these raw emotions, all of
these things that are like underneath
that I regulate. That's really who I am.
Mhm. But if you sort of look at it like
from a developmental and psychiatric
perspective, everything right underneath
what you show the rest of the world,
that's what people think myself is,
right? It's the it's the person that I
am. It's the unfiltered thoughts.
Mhm. But that is not you, right?
Yeah. And I think that's that's the main
twist. But I I think this is where like
as a psychiatrist like what are we
underneath what we show? We're like a
pile of disorganized attachment styles,
mental conditioning, like mental
habituation, a lot of internalized
shoulds, haves, whatever, right? So when
someone says
you know, if someone
can't handle me at my worst, they don't
deserve me at my best, there's a core
like
brutal, unlovable part and they want
that acceptance. And so it's kind of
weird but like you know, I I I think
that the parts underneath you
kind of need to be fixed, need to be
healed. I'm sure you don't use the word
fixed but
I do, right? So so one of the
interesting things is I I I do think
that if you look at it from like a
clinical perspective, there is a bad way
for your mind to function and there is a
good way for your mind to function. That
what your what you perceive as yourself
to be is actually a pile of like
microtraumas that have built up into
something that I would call ego or a hum
god and I think that's the big missing
step. So a lot of this like finding
authenticity
is about actually getting rid of your
ego. Mhm. And it's interesting cuz Joe
keeps on using the word love.
I don't know what that word means. Mhm.
Yeah. Right? So so I I sure we're
talking about the same thing, but that
language has never made Like the concept
of self-love, if you ask me today, do I
love myself?
I I I don't know what that means. I I
just am.
Mhm. You know, I I don't have a I would
even say like the goal is to not even
have a relationship with yourself.
Because the moment that you have a
relationship with yourself, a
relationship is between two things.
And my path to self-acceptance,
I wouldn't even call it self-acceptance
because that
That means that someone is doing the
accepting and something is being
accepted. Mhm. And that's actually
duality. That's division. That's not the
real self. That's a very subtle form of
ego. Right? And I don't know if that
makes sense or we can get into that,
right? So, so it it just the the word
love has always been confusing to me
because I don't know like what people
mean by that. Yeah. So,
it's interesting. There's
There's two pieces I want to go down. I
want to address that because I see the
semantics that are
that
that can be switched around for us to to
see that we're talking about the same
thing that I think we know we're talking
about the same thing. And then
um but there's one other part that I
want to talk about, which is there's a
brilliant design to humanity is what I
notice. And um
and it relates here, which is
the first part of it So, call it two
parts, right? The first part of it is
that uh
the feeling that I'm trying to avoid
feeling, I'm inviting in exactly the way
that I'm trying to avoid it.
So, if I don't want to feel like I'm a
loser,
then I am going to do all these things,
play guitar, da da da, get the girl, so
I don't feel like a loser. Mhm.
And in that, you got to feel like a a
loser, right? So, we do I when I was
when I was in my 20s, I it was
abandonment. I emotionally abandoned My
dad was an alcoholic. It was like my mom
was in Al-Anon. There was just no way I
was going to be emotionally abandoned.
So, every time I started to feel that
abandonment, I would do one of two
things.
Yeah, fine.
Mhm. Which I clearly made somebody
abandon me, or I would be
Could could you could
Would you please? Mhm. Which also makes
people abandon you.
And so, I was inviting the thing.
The reason that our our system does
that, as far as I can tell, is that
when we are
when we were younger, we got certain
things set in place that said
the micro traumas
which basically said, "You're not
allowed to feel this thing.
Don't feel like a loser. You're not
allowed to feel like a loser. You're not
allowed to feel unloved." If I felt
abandoned by my parents, I'd be like
crap. Like the people who are supposed
to take care of me aren't taking care of
me. Like it would just that devastation.
Don't feel that. Mhm. And so,
I'm keep on recreating circumstances to
bring that emotion back up so that it
can finally be welcomed and loved. And
so,
so for me, what that means is literally,
if you think about the love part of it,
and I don't do it because
I'm supposed to love and accept myself
all as is, though that's exactly what
I'm doing. It's also in a using slightly
different language, it's also the most
efficient way I found to heal those
micro traumas, which is
micro traumas generally are here's a
whole bunch of part of you that weren't
loved and accepted. And so, you have
contorted yourself out of who you are
to get the love and acceptance that
never actually fulfills.
Mhm.
So, okay, I won't be scared, Mom. I'll
be strong, Mom. And that like now that
part of you is unloved, and it's in the
background. And so, your authenticity in
in my language is all the unloved parts
being able to be there. And so, the most
the very most effective way
and you can't jump to it. You have to
actually There's some steps. But
eventually, the most effective way that
I notice is to love the parts of
yourself that you are not accepting. And
well, the other word would be welcoming
the parts of yourself that are
accepting.
The reason I use love is because there's
a visceral felt sense of oh, I If you
think about a puppy or a
niece or nephew or a child, there's a
feeling that you have
that you're like oh, that oh, and you
there's a softness
often like tears if you really let it
in. There's a almost of a heartbreak and
and it's like oh, I feel that towards
the dog or the kitten or my son or my
daughter.
What is it like to actually turn that
towards myself? What is it like to
actually s-
viscerally, somatically go oh,
that love towards myself. Mhm.
And
just like essentially, you're like
there's nothing wrong with you, but
there is
but there is these things do need to be
fixed and we'll we'll say that so that
you can have that moment. Similarly,
there is from what I notice from myself
for a long time and for most people that
I work with, there is two sets two sides
of the self. And this is what I notice
is
this is one of the paths, one of
probably 10 paths that I'm aware of that
allow people to actually get out of
duality into non-duality. Mhm. And so,
yeah, we're we're both saying yes, we'll
agree with you that there is a problem
here so that it's a more effective way
to work on it. But essentially, there's
not really a problem. Mhm. And and it's
very confusing.
so yeah, I know it's confusing. So I
like I I yeah, I I think it's clear to
me that Joe and I are on the same page.
I think it's just this is what's so
fascinating. This is what I love about
listening to you talk and watching you
work with people is we're clearly
starting from the same place and we end
up in the same place, but our routes
there are very different.
Very different. Yeah. So it's
interesting cuz I I
and I think we get and maybe this will
make sense, but so when someone comes
into my office and they're like, "Dr. K,
I'm having problems."
And what I'll say is like, "Yeah, bro.
You are having problems." I think this
is the key thing.
We can fix them, but it's okay for you
to be flawed. Mhm. Right? It It's not
that you're not flawed. I think this is
where the the language of
self-acceptance and self-love I've just
seen it clinically get into bad places.
Yeah. And I think this is something
about the way that you use it. I think
you understand it in a way, you see it
exist in a way that I think that when
people say like self-love that means
letting the degenerate parts of me run
wild, right? And this could also be like
by virtue of who we work with on
average.
Yeah. And so I I think where I kind of
come from is like, yeah, if you're like
if your life is screwed up like I agree.
Let's fix but it's okay for it to be
screwed up.
Right. Right? It It like up until this
point you have tried reflexively to fix
these things. And And what Joe stumbled
into, and this is what really blows my
mind, is like I think it was Freud who
originally coined the term like
repetition compulsion. So this is
something that is very very common and
and well-known in psychology that we
continue and not only in psychology,
also in Eastern spirituality, but we
continue to create when we try to fix
the problems in our life, we just create
those problems.
Mhm. And And And Joe offered a really
great example that I'd love to flesh
out. So I work with a lot of people with
um narcissistic personality disorder,
borderline personality disorder,
sociopathy. And these people like, you
know, in borderline personality disorder
you have a fear of abandonment.
And so what happens is when you're in a
relationship with someone, you're like,
"This person is going to abandon me
eventually."
And then they're like, "Charlie, don't
abandon me. Don't go. Don't go. Don't
go." And in in cuz that never gets
satisfied. And you're like, "I'm not
going to abandon you." Like, "Tell me
you love me, Charlie."
Mhm. I do. I do. No, you do You love me
You love me You love me today. Oh. But
what about tomorrow? Yeah, and then it's
like I told you six times. Yeah, and
then and then and then
and then what happens is that that right
there, right? So so I I hopefully like
people see that in face, right? And and
then people with borderline personality
disorder, they are very sensitive to
faces. Mhm. So if you're smiling right
now and 10% of your face is actually
frowning, which is really weird, but you
can do that, right? You can tell when
the smile doesn't hit someone's eyes,
someone with BPD will ignore the 90% of
the smile and they will see the 10% in
your the lack of love in your eyes.
They'll see the frustration. And so what
they end up doing is since I'm never
reassured by you, I'm like Charlie love
me, love me, love me. And then what I'm
going to do do is drive you [__]
crazy.
Yeah. You can't handle it anymore and
then you're like I just need a day away
from your anxieties and then suddenly
I've created the abandonment that I
feared. Yeah. And each time it happens,
the wound gets deeper and deeper and
deeper and then I'm hungry for the next
person to love me and hungry for the
next person to love me.
Mhm. And on the Eastern side, that's
kind of this weird like cycle of karma
that the Buddha sort of talks about,
right? He says like we get trapped in
this cycle of karma.
And like the more that you try to
escape, like it's like a Chinese finger
trap where like the the harder you pull
the way life is, which I I
I mean I love you Joe, but like when
you're like oh the human being is
beautiful, I'm like we're also like
fundamentally flawed and entrapped in
this cycle of karma, right? So many of
our survival reactions and and that's
what happens, you learn like this
avoidant attachment stuff, anxious
attachment stuff.
I agree we're beautiful, but also we're
like fundamentally kind of like the way
that we survive our problems
creates problems for us. And it requires
so much work and insight to sort of get
there and and that's why Joe and I have
jobs because
Yeah. You know, so it it's it's
fascinating. Yeah. And it's interesting
as you were talking, it's exactly almost
the opposite in my approach, which is
somebody comes to me and like, I have a
problem. I'm like,
prove it.
And they can't. Yeah. So so like it's
it's an interesting thing, but both
work. And it's it's an interesting
What's interesting to me about it is
that if you
There's this thing about
just the developmental process that I
get really that I geek out on, but a
very interesting way to think about it
is There was a time in my life where the
word nowadays is agency, but I needed to
know that I could control that I had
agency, that I was choosing my life,
that life was a choice. Because I felt
disempowered, I felt oppressed
by my parents, etc. So I needed to I'm I
have a choice. And that offered me great
relief.
And the way I say it now is every
epiphany is a rut waiting to happen.
And then just a little bit later,
whatever decade, I guess just a little
bit later, all of a sudden that feeling
of choice was a burden to me. Mhm. That
to see life as a gift, to see that every
one of my thoughts was not something
that I was choosing, that I couldn't
even choose to stop my thinking,
that every time I had gratitude, that
was a gift. That created relief in my
system. And so there is this
there is a a time and a place for
for the methodology. Yeah.
No matter what it is, like it's not
about is it the right thought? It is Is
that the useful thought today in this
moment? And there's definitely a time
where it is incredibly useful to say,
"Yeah, you're [__] up and that's
okay." And there's also a time that's
really useful to say,
"Prove it." Prove it.
Yeah. Yeah. Can I share with you a model
that has really helped me with this?
Because I have been
the everything is a rut has been so
challenging for me cuz I was like, I've
already tried surrendering. I did that
when I was 15. It didn't go well.
So You can't surrender.
We'll get into that. So the the model is
I think it think it comes from Michael
Beckwith, but it's you're I'm sure
you're familiar like to me, by me,
through me, as me. And if you're not,
it's this idea that
people start in something called victim
consciousness, which is life is
happening to me. And I live in a state
of like, whose fault is it that things
suck so much, basically, and just please
don't be my fault. It's somebody else's.
The big leap to the next stage, by me,
is no, I'm taking responsibility. I'm
taking control. And this is where I
live. That conversation didn't go well,
it's not because we're not a match, it's
because I could have been more verbally
fluent or been funnier or smiled wider,
whatever it is.
And so most of
personal development, you might call it,
occurs in this by me stage. I'm taking
control of my finances, my health, my
everything.
And then where I feel like I've recently
gotten to is the pain of that, the
endless responsibility of having
Sounds exhausting.
It's so Well, at first it's liberating.
And then it's a cage. It's it's
horrible.
And so the end of that is
you step into through me, which is where
I feel like I'm starting, where you
allow gratitude to move through you, uh
grace to move through you, uh miraculous
I don't know what I'm going to say, but
here's me to move through you.
And that has helped me a lot to not feel
like I'm just moving backwards into this
victim consciousness. And I've And I can
subtly now, oh, they're not the same.
You said you can't surrender at the
beginning. And
I guess I'm starting to get that these
are fundamentally different approaches.
Yeah. What's after through me? As me,
which is So life moves through me,
there's still a separation. Is there
something as me?
Life is as I I I just Is there Is there
something after that? I think it's just
as me in in the stage. What do you
think? Yeah, there is. 100%
Oh, come on. Hit me. 100% Yeah, I'm
having a hard time verbalizing it, but I
think I Yeah, so so so I would I easy.
Just as. as
Just
The as long as there's a me, there's one
more step.
Mhm.
Right? So so like I was going to say is,
but yeah. Yeah. But again, language is
really weird. It gets really weird here.
Yeah, but I I think there's absolutely
one more step. Yeah. A five stick cool.
I I mean, I don't My guess is there's no
there's a probably a dozen steps after
that, too. My experience is evolution
doesn't end. It's not like there's not
some place where you're like, "Boom.
Done." Yeah. Yeah. But there's
definitely something past as.
100%
But I would have to know his definition
There's a you could geek out on this
forever.
Yeah.
But what I do notice about the
developmental cycle generally is that
each new phase isn't a a a a a
an It's an It's an integration as well.
So you're you're you're you're you're
seeing something new, but you can't stop
the integration. Meaning, I am walking,
but it doesn't mean I now can't crawl.
Yeah.
So that's interesting cuz I I think you
know, in in psychiatry, we have a great
phrase that really stuck with me, which
is growing up is the process of
abandoning what works. Yeah. Yeah.
Right? So so if you look at people who
have these patterns in their life where
they're stuck like chasing like Okay,
like you So so it sounds like you did it
all, Charlie. You got in shape. You like
learned how to play guitar.
Exhausted it. multiple languages, right?
Yeah. So like you had something and it
it worked, right? Like you got the girl
at 24 and then got the girl at 25 and
then got the girl at 26 and you keep on
doing more and more. It's working. Mhm.
The process of really growing up is
getting rid of what what works. So you
you kind of refer to it as an
integration. I I know it's going to be
weird but I think we're golden, but
Yeah. I would call it disintegration,
right? I would call it getting rid of
something like literally getting rid of
something. So getting rid of your old
patterns, getting rid of and so going to
this place of
even there's no me left, right? So
you're like getting rid of a certain
pattern of interaction. And like a good
example is like when you're two, you can
kind of cry and you can get away with
it. I have some patients that continue
to have temper tantrums when they're
like 26, 27, 68,
and they're throwing temper tantrums.
And in order for them to grow, they have
to get rid of the thing that their
spouse tolerated that allowed them to
get their way is what you sort of have
to get rid of.
Yeah. Yeah, absolutely. Both are true.
There's an integration and a
disintegration. Yeah,
and especially with the sense of self,
there's a disintegration. But even in
that, there's also then my experience
this I think we're going we're going to
jump the shark. Until we get to the what
am I question, we can talk about like
where that goes, but yeah, I don't want
to get there.
I'm out of my depth now, so I want to
let you guys steer from here on out.
think we're okay. Like let let me just
ask like Charlie, can you summarize
what we've covered so far? Like where
are we right now? Okay,
I appreciate that. Cuz I think we got to
go there and it I don't know how much
longer we stay there.
started with this this idea of charisma
and what is it? It's it's a ability to
vision and communicate clearly and to
listen well, and there's all of these
behaviors. And then what I heard, this
is my as I piece it together with my own
understanding is
there's a social mask that is "Hi
everyone, you know, it's it's that
thing." Then there's what I'm going to
call an ego, which is you have to take
me and accept me and I like I am this
thing and there's it's an unconscious
belief of this is what I am, and there's
something
deeper than that
that is I'll call the self here
um that is unified and has the
uh uh
effortless quality of charisma, it
sounds like in this. And that at
different stages of one's life, there
are many different approaches. There's a
to to doing it. And one is to
fix all of the surface-level problems to
get the girl to do the thing, to do the
this, to do the that. And another way in
is to realize
I there never was a problem. I didn't
need the girl.
Um,
and my way has been, you know, I guess
you could call it top-down. Yeah. Um,
and it sounds like
that was our way. Yeah.
Sure.
So so beautiful. Yeah. So I'm thinking
um, if you have There's there's one more
piece to it that I think would actually
tie it together. So in
the Greek
of charisma, it was a uh
a
like is a god-given gift or god's given
gift. It's this It's this thing that you
don't actually get to
you don't you get choice in. It's just a
gift. Mhm. And I think most people take
that as some people were given it and
some people weren't given it.
And
I I don't know how they meant it. But my
I my guess is somebody along the line
meant it as
No, that that's the gift all of us are
given.
And whether you call that gift
the thing that is not separated inside
of ourselves or you call it awareness or
you call it a disintegrated sense of I
or you call it the evaporation of ego or
whatever that is,
that
that thing is probably what they're
talking and pointing to when they say
like the religious people often have a
huge sense of ego or and I'm sorry, huge
sense of um, that's That's true.
Very common. Yeah. Um, also have this
sense of
of
that
that divine gift that we all have. And
so there there they see and feel that
and live through that process often,
even if it's distorted through drama or
whatever.
They have that thing and and that's
where we're we're pointing to when we
start talking about the self and what is
the self and
is is is that is is starting to see that
the ego, which you defined as
I think I'm this and this and this. I
also define it as I don't think I'm this
and this and this, right? Somebody says
No, no, I'm not that pretty. Also ego.
I'm not a loser. I'm not a loser. Also
ego.
Um and so
so there is this
so and and when I'm speaking to
um
the idea of there's your authentic self,
that's what I'm speaking to. Mhm. Right?
I'm not saying you need to be fixed
because that doesn't need to be fixed.
Mhm. That but and absolutely there's
work that needs to be done for you to be
able to see
into that shore, yeah.
to to understand that's who you are.
Huh. So that's the Yeah, so if I I I'm
sort of feeling like
I'm going to offer some language
that and and maybe once we if you all
like the language and it feels like it's
it's a model that kind of works, then we
can get to the real stuff.
Yeah, yeah. So, you know,
and it blows my mind once again, Joe,
that like you like I don't know how you
learned this stuff, but like you know, I
I I spent like literally years, maybe
you did too, but years in India and
South Korea and Japan and stuff like in
monasteries and and things like that.
But so I I like this term Ahumkar, which
is the Sanskrit word that loosely gets
translated as ego, but the technical
translation is the feeling of I.
Right? So anytime you say I am
, that is not actually what
you are. Mhm. That is the ego. Right? So
this is where when when Joe is saying,
"I'm a winner," that's ego. "I'm a
loser," that's also ego. Mhm.
And and so I know it sounds kind of
weird because we think we are these
things, but like I'm a doctor.
Right? Like that's if if I were to say
I'm a doctor, everyone would agree. But
like show me. Yeah. Right? Show Where is
the doctor in me? Like you can't find
it. It's not a real thing. It's a
construction.
Right? So so And this is where people
will say like it So all of the
attributes Anything that you
If you say I am
Anything that comes after that statement
is part of ego. And this is really
confusing for people because if I say I
am a man,
right? And cuz everyone's like oh like
that's like that's biological, right?
Where I I'm not trying to get into like
gender rights or whatever. I mean like
in a very technical sense. Forget about
morality and what's right or whatever.
Let's Let's talk scientifically. How do
I know I'm a man? Like Charlie, are you
man?
Um first blush is yes. Yeah, so how do
you know?
Um I look at my genitals. I
let's say you have testicular cancer,
you have to have your testicles removed.
Right? So this is like work that I've
literally done. I've I've had patients
who have a double bracket negative
mutation who have to have double
prophylactic mastectomies.
I've had patients who have
hysterectomies. The uterus needs to be
taken out at the age of 24 because
they've got really bad fibroids. If I
remove your genitals, are you still a
man?
Uh
I don't know. I am I think so.
Um Right? So then some people will say
like you're you still have XY
chromosomes.
Mhm. Right. Right? So is that where man
comes from? Mhm. Is it the genitals?
Mhm. Like which part of what part of you
makes you a man? And ultimately
everything can be taken and will be it
seems like, right? Right? So so this is
where even there's so many foundational
things about our identity where I I love
Joe's language of like show me. Mhm.
Like prove it to me, right? And we're so
trapped in this idea that I am
something.
Whereas if we really look at like kind
of what we are, you know, you change,
your thoughts change, your emotions
change, your identity changes,
your body changes.
So, none of those are really what makes
you you, right? Like, if I lost an arm,
I'd still be me. I was still me before I
graduated from medical school. Mhm.
People think that you become a medical
doctor when you get your your piece of
paper and you finish medical school. I
know the day I became a doctor, it was 6
months after I got my MD degree. It was
like when I was on call and someone
asked for my help and my senior was
unavailable and I was able to handle it.
Mhm. It That's when I was at a wedding
and someone was like, "Is there a doctor
here?" And you're like, "Okay, yeah, no,
this person doesn't need to go to the
hospital. It's a panic attack, not a
heart attack. If I'm wrong, they die."
Mhm. Right? And so, like, there there
are moments where we have this feeling
of becoming, but that's not really who
we are. So, the ahankara is when you say
when you say to yourself, "I am a
winner" or "I am a loser," it feels that
way and it feels true to you and that's
the way the ego is. But, if you kind of
think about it, like, I can't biopsy you
and find either of those things.
And so, a lot of what we're talking
about in terms of this deeper charisma,
this authenticity,
that comes from the layer, that divine
connection, comes from the layer beneath
ego. Because as long as you're chasing
ego, you're going to get back to this
trap that we talked about with you where
it's like, "I'm going to be better. I'm
going to be better. I'm going to be
better." But, the more that you become
that thing and the more that people love
the shell that you become, "I'm going to
become rich. I'm going to become
handsome." Mhm.
It doesn't actually solve the problem.
Right? And this is how you become
narcissistic.
This is how you become hyper-sensitive
to other people's judgments. This is why
you can't leave the house unless you get
a nose job. Mhm. That's all the growth
of the ego. So, this is the The biggest
problem is that so many of the things
that we do to fix the problems in our
life, as Joe said, just make them worse.
It's really well said. The way I give
people a direct, potentially a direct
experience of this is
like
try to get in touch with the thing that
you've always been.
Like that there's never been one moment
that that hasn't been true.
And there's a
there's a sense that happens is there
the words can't come to mind, but
there's a sense of that.
Which is that place that is beyond the
ego.
And
there's this very weird thing, and I'm
really curious about your thinking on
this, which is there's a again, every
epiphany is a rut waiting to happen.
There's a place where
fighting the ego, really important, like
disintegrating the ego, really
important. There's also a place where
it's really important to say, "Oh, there
is no ego."
That's just an illusion. That that whole
thing was like a
you know, that happens in apparently,
from what I understand
from neuroscience, is that
the sense of I happens in the same part
of the brain that hallucinates.
So like
is that do you know about that? I would
not say that.
Okay. But we can get into that if you
want.
I know I just it was an article I read
and I was
but generally there is just a um
there is like a that sense of self is at
some point there's a time when it's
really important to
to like see through it and to work work
at it and then there's also a part where
there's just like a you know, I think
there's a there was an Irish mystic
named Wei Wu Wei, and he said
um
"Fight your ego, try to destroy your
ego, try to see through your ego. The
only problem is that it doesn't exist."
And I remember after 10 years of
fighting it, that moment gave me massive
relief to read that.
I don't think it would have if I hadn't
fought it for 10 Yeah.
So I I I a couple of of thoughts on just
to kind of pile on to that. Yeah. So
first is, you know, I think the ego, we
know where sort of comes from in the
brain and it's fascinating. So
the the ego most likely comes from
something called our default mode
network, which is our sense of self. So
the default mode network is the ability
for you to like recognize that you have
an identity, right? So when you look in
the mirror, you don't see a face, you
see you, right? Like you have like an
identification with that. That's
probably default mode network. The
really interesting thing is a
hyperactive default mode network
is
what makes you depressed.
So if you look at if you talk to someone
who's clinically depressed, I'm a loser.
Mhm. My family is better off without me.
It's always me me me me me me me. I
can't do this, I can't do that. And they
don't think about anyone except for
themselves in a weird way, right? So
like if you're really struggling with
depression, you'll notice that you're
looking at yourself, you're thinking
about yourself. I go out to with my I go
out with my friends, I'm thinking about
how I look, I'm thinking about how they
would have more fun if I wasn't here.
I'm thinking about how I should have
jumped into that conversation. I had
something really funny to say, but I
didn't know how to jump in and now I'm
not saying anything and now I'm just
sitting here and like And they're like
the exact opposite of charismatic.
Absolutely. They are like the they are
the people that everyone's like, "Oh
god, could you I just don't want to work
with you. I don't Please don't sit next
to me. No no no, they're coming over."
Mhm. They're the people. They're
creating that reality and it's because
they're the farthest away from that
authenticity, sense of self, whatever
you want to call it. So I I think I just
to love the way you brought that back.
So I think the more internally divided
you are, that fundamental charisma
So you can be
um car salesman charisma by being
internally divided. You can think one
thing and be slick on top. Yeah.
That doesn't last long. Yeah.
The core of this charisma I think we're
talking about is to not be internally
divided. As long as you are feeling
anxious and pretending to be confident,
you can pretend to be confident. You can
appear confident. You will never be
charismatic. I feel like we've gotten to
a really important core, which is this
lack of internal division or just a
wholeness. Absolutely, right? So, that's
the that's where the authenticity cuz
the moment that I have something within
me and I'm pretending to be something
else, that's not
authentic.
And and that when I'm pointing to when
I'm saying be yourself, Mhm. it is that
sense of wholeness that I am pointing
to. Mhm. It is that thing Oh, wait,
that's the thing that I've always been.
And when you went there in your mind or
the people are listening if they went
there,
that wasn't like two parts. Mhm. That
was a sense of of of oneness maybe not
even with self but with everything. Mhm.
Yeah, so beautiful. So, I think this is
what's really cool about the default
mode network. So, if we look at the
fastest acting So, default mode network
is over activation of default Sorry,
depression is over activation of default
mode network, right? So, I'm constantly
thinking about myself. The fastest
treatment pharmacological treatment for
depression is ketamine. And ketamine is
or was originally not a psychiatric
agent. It was used as an anesthesia.
Still is.
Tranquilizer, yeah. A dissociative
agent.
Okay. Okay. So, tranquilizer puts you to
sleep. It doesn't put you to sleep.
You're actually awake with ketamine.
Okay. It dissociates you. So, your sense
of self disappears.
So, this is the other cool thing.
Meditation deactivates the default mode
network.
The other really cool thing is
psychedelics.
So, Yeah, or Well, well, well, let me
finish. Let me finish. I know. I know.
I'm with you. I'm with you. You're going
to say the opposite and we're still
going to agree.
So, so psychedelics this is what's
really fascinating. If if you look at
the studies on psychedelic healing,
so people will ask people when you take
a psychedelic, what do you experience?
If you see colors, if you see cool
things, you don't actually heal.
The the the subjective experience that
correlates with trauma improvement,
depression improvement with psychedelic
substance use is ego death, ego
dissolution, deactivation of the default
mode network. And it is the sense that
even at your deepest self
you know, there there's the surface
thoughts, then there's the ego, and then
at that deepest self self, you're not
even you, you're everything.
So, people who experience the sense of
interconnectedness
come out of that experience with a
different perception of themselves. I am
no longer a doctor, I'm no longer All
Oak, I'm no longer a man. Yep. And
that's literally the default mode
network, and this is what why I feel
really strongly about it. I I'm
confident this is correct because we
have three different, you know,
meditation, psychedelics, and ketamine
all activate this thing. We know it's
hyperactivated. So, that's kind of like
how we get to that self. Yeah.
Okay, I'm going to geek out for a
minute. First of all,
uh
I want to just put a warning out to
anybody who's listening to this.
Ketamine is highly addictive. I have
seen some great human beings get
completely [__] destroyed by that
drug.
Agreed. Don't use ketamine. Yeah, so so
uh
yeah, or use it really sparingly, really
well with a really great
uh people with you, but
so, that that's one thing I want to say
just because I've I've suffered personal
grief and loss through that. Um
The second thing is, I agree meditation
does exactly what you're saying. At a
point, meditation does exactly what
you're saying. There is a point where
people meditate and how they meditate,
they're reinforcing their ego. And so,
so there's also that. So, if you're
meditating in a way where you're not
trying to manage yourself or control
yourself, then it's a higher chance of
that disintegration happening than when
you're trying to manage and control
yourself. Saying that because I did that
for a decade, and I know exactly what
that's like. Yeah.
Which I think is actually part of the
journey and important. Um
So, that that's the things there. I
think the I I I couldn't agree more with
the
a default mode network. I I love I
didn't know about that. It's like such
an amazing Yeah, please. That that is
really cool. And
my experiences, those are three ways to
do it, and there's other ways to do it,
too. A sense of loving yourself it I
find also does that same thing.
Because one of the aspects of the
somatic experience of love is that
you're not giving or receiving
anymore. Like if you deeply go into that
state, it's a lot like a like a an
amazing orgasm that you might have. Like
not the kind of like a porn
orgasm, but the orgasm where you
disintegrate is another place where you
can where you can find that love is
another place you can find that.
Um deep intimate relationship is also a
place you will you're starting noticing
will do this thing with groups where
you've got like six or seven people
and this person is anxious, this person
is anxious. And we'll ask this person to
hold the anxiety and literally feel the
anxiety, and they can basically no
longer feel it.
It's an ability it's an it's a I don't
understand it.
So, I'm just trying to understand even
the logistics of it. So, you're in a
group of people, two people are feeling
anxious, you ask one of them to hold?
No, no. Uh let's say we're working with
one person and they're going through
something.
And we'll ask people to hold their
emotional states, and it makes it in a
group it makes it that other people
can't hold the emotional state. It's a
really fast Let me Let me make it really
practical. You've got a
a husband and wife dynamic. And the
husband always worries about money, and
the wife is always like, "Ah, relax.
It's okay." And then one day the
husband's like, "I don't know, I'm not
worried about money anymore."
Guaranteed.
The
Yeah, or you're in a business meeting,
and there's the naysayer. And finally,
the team's just like, "I'm done with
this naysayer, we're going to get rid of
this naysayer, and then come back to
that group in a month and there's a new
naysayer. Huh. So, there's this
interesting dynamic of seeing when you
see yourself through a community,
there's a sense of self that
disintegrates. The most
the best experience of this where when
this is fully understood happens in um
that I've ever heard I can't even
pronounce her name, unfortunately, but
um
it's a these tribe in in Africa where if
the
if there is a husband and wife they're
having a problem they don't see it as a
husband and wife problem, they see it as
a community problem.
Mhm. This is this is the way that in
Ayurvedic medicine my fingernail is kind
of rigid-y, that means it's a digestive
problem, which I can also see in my
eyes. They see this as a an symptom of a
community problem. And so, the entire
community comes and works with that with
that couple to heal the
that because that's how they're going to
heal the community. I feel really moved
as you talk about that, yeah. It's
beautiful.
also is a disintegration of the sense of
I.
Mhm. That it's not actually me.
So, it's there I think there's lots of
ways to do it, and every single one of
them that I've ever run across
deeply healing.
Crazy healing. And as a matter of fact,
when we do some of the work where we're
asking other people to hold emotions,
this that experience of non-duality of
seeing self as everything happens
consistently. Mhm.
So, there's like there there's lots of
modalities that that I have found or
experimented or played with that bring
that thing in every single one of them
deeply deeply healing.
They restore wholeness by
No. No? No. They show that we are whole.
Yeah, restore implies it wasn't there to
begin with. Exactly, right? So, so yeah,
I mean, I I think there's got to be a
second conversation. So, I just call
that when I teach that to my patients, I
call it an emotional umbilical cord.
Mhm. So, you're just connected, and
emotions pass back and forth. Yeah. Um
it's a really useful technique to use
from a manipulative standpoint. Right?
So, if you're like like in a challenging
work environment,
Yep. um like I I call So, someone taught
this to me, one of my mentors, sitting
in someone's seat. Right? So, if someone
has a pattern of behavior Yeah. and you
start engaging in that pattern of
behavior, it'll flip. Yep. There's a
certain amount of energy and I don't I'm
just using that as a general There's
There's a certain amount of stuff that
is non-physical that exists between us.
Mhm. And if I don't hold it, you will.
And this has been shown in research. So,
like Okay. Cuz I I I want to go back to
it, but this is really cool. So, if you
have a child with an anxiety disorder
and you have a parent with an anxiety
disorder, if you treat the parent
without touching the child,
whatever benefit the parent gets will
get translated over, not one-to-one, but
will basically get translated over into
the child. Oh, yeah.
Right? So, we we we share emotions and
there's all kinds of empathic circuits
that get activated. This is also where
like charisma kind of comes in. Right?
So, when you're authentic
and you're not internally divided, when
there's no car salesman, right? So, like
when we're sitting with a car salesman,
we kind of get convinced and this is why
they use tactics like time share
presentations. They know that we're not
going to trust them. So, they
emotionally manipulate us. Yeah. They
figure out how to do that. But even when
you're in that situation, you can
empathically detect that undercurrent of
what they're not sharing with you. Mhm.
So, the more unified you are, the more
authentic you are, the more not yourself
you are, the more connected you are, the
more that will create this dyad of
charisma.
That takes us back to the beginning of
the dyad. I love it. I love it. So, I I
think the one thing that um
you know, we've talked a little bit
about is like Charlie's journey, Joe had
a journey. It sounds very similar to my
own in the sense of you have to go
through the motions, you know, you have
to kind of do things the wrong way to
realize it doesn't work.
Um one of my favorite stories about this
is if you sort of look at these
spiritual leaders from the Indian
subcontinent.
In ancient India, we had four castes and
the Brahmins were at the top and they're
the priests, they're the teachers of
meditation, they're the gurus. Then you
have the kings, the Kshatriyas below
them, they're like nobility.
The really interesting thing is that all
of the enlightened people not all, all
the famous enlightened people that come
out of the Indian subcontinent, none of
them are priests. None of them are
meditation teachers.
They're all kings. So Buddha was a king,
Krishna was a king, Ram was a king.
These are considered incarnations of
Vishnu.
Um even Mahavira, the the founder of
Jainism is like was a king. Hm. So one
time I I had a question for a teacher of
mine. I was like, why are all the kings
getting enlightened and none of the
priests?
And and the answer is really
interesting. It's that you have to
chase material things,
get them, and then realize it doesn't
work.
Right? So if I if I tell anyone at home
like, oh yeah, like discover your true
self and like you don't need to get the
girl to be happy. There's a seed of like
I don't know that, right? You have to
actually try something, realize that it
is insufficient to really look for
something more.
So you guys both have these
conversations with people on the
internet, you coach. Yeah.
Tell me Yeah, you're listening from your
gut, you're picking up things. Like what
what is going on as for both of you cuz
you're
what I see is you seem to make people
have these intellectual breakthroughs
where they sort of see themselves in a
different way and I've also and you'll
people will cry or laugh or just unfold
or unwind in some way?
Yeah.
And what is going on in each of those
encounters, those ways of being?
Uh uh the the most
most essential is I'm listening.
My experience is I'm listening. I'm
listening to myself. I'm listening to
them.
Um uh I'm
I'm
vulnerable in the listening and in the
asking of questions. I'll often ask
questions where I literally pucker to
ask the question and I usually know that
that's a really good question. There's
that feeling of vulnerability.
There's a deep impartiality in me
even though it doesn't look like it,
where I I don't think I need to get that
person anywhere. I'm not there to help
them.
This isn't There's just There's not a
lot of I in the equation. So, often
times at the end of it I don't remember
what happened. I don't know if it went
well.
And I don't care. It's like none of that
When I say I don't care, I don't mean I
try not to care. I mean, I don't even
conceive of it. Care.
Um and then deeply empathetic, I'm
feeling the thing they're feeling. So,
often times if I'm working with somebody
and I'll say, "Yeah, what's going on in
your gut?" I can't even see it, but
because I'm so empathetically in with
them that I I'm actually I'm able to
feel it. I feel through my own body,
through my own system.
So, we've talked about that you said
that navel or the umbilical cord. How do
we feel that more effectively? How do we
attune empathetically?
Is Is that something we've already
discussed?
My experience generally, and I think
this isn't a place where we might we
might might disagree.
Um
there's a a Zen story about
the young and an old monk walking down
the path and the
young monk says, "Oh, I can start to
like know what people are thinking."
He's like, "Ah, what does that have to
do with awakening?"
"Oh, I can read people's thoughts. What
does that have to be awakening?" Like as
he walks through, he's going having all
these different things. And my
experience is
that if you go after trying to figure
those skills out
it can be incredibly destructive. It can
be like chasing money. It can be like
chasing sex. It's it it it can really
destroy somebody. It can
create a much
more solid
form of ego. Whereas if you allow that
stuff to unfold naturally because of
your own self-awareness
So that's how I would recommend the path
I would recommend is to understand
yourself more and more and more and more
and the more you understand yourself
this stuff naturally occurs. So tuning
to your own gut to your own heart.
Correct. And then when you're listening
to someone you'll just feel it's like oh
I feel Yeah, so I did this form of
breathwork for like 7 years or so where
it was
kind of
an extinct form of Reiki and breathwork
that I would do.
And
when I was
two three years into it I could look at
somebody's body and know what emotions
they were holding and like how they were
raised.
Not because anybody said this arc means
critical parent and this means like I'm
an unavailable mother.
Right? It was because I actually just
went through all that stuff in myself.
And so that's the way I recommend doing
it because that's the thing that
actually gets you to the freedom that
you're really looking for beyond the
power of being able to do it.
Yeah, I've I've had it's that times a
spreadsheet approach which is like you
know if you know she posts these kind of
photos on Instagram the dad wasn't there
you know whatever it is and one people
don't like to be analyzed that way even
if it's
true and it is not actual empathy. It is
a repetition of what someone who had
empathetic attunement might might have
said in the moment. Yeah.
Okay, so that makes sense. Go through
oneself and it'll just sort of unfold
what's going on with you when you're
having your conversation.
question is what
why did you think that would be a point
of our disagreement?
Because it sounded like there was some
part of the traditions that you had
it would actually yeah so it was an
assumption on my part about Kundalini
work. Okay.
Which is that often times there's
oh this is the thing that you will get
from this Kundalini work that I've seen
in the real world. So that's where I
thought we might disagree. Yeah so I I I
mean
I don't think we're going to disagree.
Okay. Okay great. Yeah I clearly when I
saw your face and
it was like you know cuz I I think like
in that the key thing That was an
assumption that that you were not not to
blame you or anything right but like
that didn't come from me it come came
from your understanding of what
Kundalini work is right? So so in a
sense
anyway I don't know
I was just kind of confused because I
was like no this is like this is exactly
this is it.
Exactly.
Can I ask you a specific question about
this? Last time you were here we sat
down after and I started sharing with
you that you know there was stuff coming
up in my life and you're and you're like
I see that. I like and I said what do
you mean you see that? You said oh third
eye [__]
And I'm curious if you could elaborate.
So so I I I think this is what's really
um
this is going to get like a touch
theoretical
Sure. but I'm not the touch theory
I realized something recently.
Credibility is very far away from truth.
Mhm.
So like
Oh I love that.
He he gets it. So I'll I'll walk y'all
through it. Yeah.
So if I want to say something that's
credible let's say I want to say
something to you and I want to make
myself credible. How do I make myself
credible if I'm talking to you? You have
to understand my world to a degree and
speak
I have to understand your world right?
So the more ignorant you are
Mhm.
the more credible I have to be. Mhm.
Mhm. You kind of get that? So
credibility only works when the like why
do we need credibility? Because we don't
know. We don't trust. We don't know that
this thing is true.
Right? That's why we need to be
credible. I need you to believe me,
but believing requires an absence of
knowledge, like by definition. Mhm. If I
know where my keys are, that's different
from believing where my keys are. One is
a statement of fact and one is a
statement of belief. One is a statement
of ignorance.
So,
one of the things that I've uh started
to do recently is like worry less about
being credible. I showed up and I tried
to be credible, but what I realized is
like credibility assumes the ignorance
of the person. But truth is truth. Mhm.
Whether people believe it or not is like
up to them. The more knowledgeable they
are, the more they will know that I'm
correct, which is why you laughed. Yeah.
Right? And and the less knowledgeable
they are, the more they'll they're
likely to think that I'm an idiot, which
is like okay. I love this. I just want
to say you've helped me a lot with this
because
the with the phrase that I've understood
from you is it is not your
responsibility to be understood. It is
your responsibility to speak the truth,
but I have often done the work of being
credible, of making myself understood,
and in such I'm diluting
the the me or whatever it is that I'm
saying. So so I I think there are times
where it's important to be credible. So
when I'm a doctor,
like I want to be credible first and
truthful second.
But there are times where there there's
there are times for credibility and
there are times for truth. This is a
conversation where I think truth comes
first. Mhm.
So, what Joe is describing
you know, as he does this kind of work
is in the Sanskrit word this is a
siddhi. I don't know if you you've heard
that term, but so so this is really
fascinating. There's like this thing
called Patanjali's Yoga Sutras, which is
like the Bible of yoga. So if you like
look at like the seminal text on what we
call yoga,
a dude or maybe lots of people named
Patanjali, woman, we don't really know,
wrote this text about what is an asana,
what is a posture, how does the mind
work? Like it's like all the really
basic stuff that modern science
basically like follows. Like all the
stuff about meditation and things like
that. Like it's basically rooted in
Patanjali or captured in Patanjali.
The third chapter, it's four chapters.
The third chapter is really short and
it's just a list of things. So he says
like in chapter one he's like in asana,
any yoga posture has two requirements.
That's it. There are all these postures,
downward dog, this, that. He says all
the postures
asanas have two things in common. One is
that they're it's stable, it's not
motion.
The second is it brings the attention to
the present. That's all an asana is. You
can make whatever asana as you want. You
can make up your own yoga postures as
long as you are stable and you are
focused on the present, that is the
asana. That's the essence. It's the
equation.
Chapter three is the development of
psychic powers. And he's like, by the
way, if you do these practices, you will
develop these these powers.
These things are not believable. Fair
enough, whatever. They're not credible,
fine. He just says, by the way, this is
what's going to happen. Addendum.
Not addendum. He's like, if you walk the
spiritual path, you will develop
abilities that will appear supernatural.
Appear. Mhm. Appear. Appear. Really
critical word. Well, it's why why we're
at it, right?
Yeah, yeah, yeah. They're not
supernatural. Yeah. They're just hard to
access. Mhm. And there's a whole
conversation which I I can go into a
bunch of detail. I I've had a lot of I'm
not saying I'm psychic or anything like
that, but there there's like
whole systems of understanding this
stuff. But these things are also
incredibly dangerous.
So I want y'all to understand and I I I
think I think Joe gets this.
Um so a little bit of what we do seems
exceptional.
It's not exceptional. So like people
will I mean it's exceptional, but it's
not supernatural. So people will like
ask me, right? So like I'm a
psychiatrist, this is how I know what I
do. No, I I I do what I do because of my
spiritual practice, not psychiatry is
there and it has a role, but my
intuition and what I know about people
in the same way that that Joe knows
things about people and stuff like that,
I don't think that that can be taught in
psychiatric training. Because if that
was taught in psychiatric training,
the majority of psychiatrists would be
able to do what I do.
And And it's not that what I do is
special, it's just like if you train in
that way, you will learn how to do that.
Very simple. Joe has trained in that
way, I have trained in that way, which
is why we both do it. You can train in
that way, anyone can train in that way.
A big part of what we do in our
community is try to teach them that
stuff so that they realize I'm not
special, you can do it, too. It is your
birthright.
Right? So, I I I get to where Joe gets,
but like I come there from a different
way, sort of. Yeah.
So, the the other thing that's really
scary is like, you know, I see these
posts sometimes on the internet of if I
were a billionaire, I would just start
fixing problems.
And And
Okay? So, this is like really a
statement of ignorance. Like the the
moment that you have great power and you
start exercising it, you realize how
much you [__] things up.
So, like the moment that you have
something really powerful, like let's
just say hypothetically, I'm not even
saying these things exist, okay? There
There are I've hypothesized
neuroscientific mechanisms through which
we can do   supernatural
things. It's not really supernatural,
it's just a finely finely attuned
empathic circuit, at attending in the
right way, like all kinds of stuff,
which we can get to in a second.
Uh about what I do. How I would explain
what I do, which I think is the same as
what you Not the same, but, you know,
the same. Yeah.
Uh There's absolutely a neuroscience
There There must be a neuroscience
correlate. The question is does
neuroscience sufficiently explain it, or
is there something beyond neuroscience?
That's a debate for philosophers.
So, what happens though is the moment
that you start exercising
these powers, you get caught, you get
trapped by life in a in a way more
vice-like grip.
And and I think this is where like, you
know, like you quoted a Zen
uh you know, parable. Yeah. I'm going to
quote, I think it's Notorious B.I.G.,
"Mo money, mo problems."
Mhm. Which like is really confusing for
people until you have it.
The number of patients that I've had
that have windfalls of cash flow,
speaking of ketamine,
will will burn through millions of
dollars of drugs.
Right? Like like their lives get And
it's not that money doesn't buy
happiness, it does. It buys happiness up
to a point. If you can't pay your bills,
like you have no financial security,
money will absolutely remove the things
that get in the way of your happiness,
but at some point the more power you
have, like you can get trapped by life
way easier. Can I just What are these
powers that you're talking And it
doesn't mean So you're using money as
like in a thing, but do you mean that
empathetic circuit? Is that what you're
saying?
No, I mean so I would refer you to the
text.
Okay.
I'm not making these claims. You guys
can read the text. But Patanjali says,
if you want telepathy, do this. If you
want to travel through time, do this. If
you want to turn into the size of an
atom or the size of a universe, do this.
Mhm. If you want to know the moment of
your death, do this. Mhm. There's a
really simple practice that I can share
with you all.
If you just breathe,
you'll notice that
your breath has a certain length.
So if you like put your hand like face
up below your nose and you breathe out,
you'll notice that the breath goes a
certain way.
Mhm. If you do that practice for a
decade, you'll understand all kinds of
things. Okay, got it.
Okay, got it.
Like you do it every day for like an
hour
for a decade. And and this is the time
scale that we're talking about. Yeah. I
started doing a month or practice 21
years ago. Mhm. In my experience, there
were basically three
levels of stuff that I got through that
that were at 7-year stretches. Mhm. I
don't know why. It's weird. Mhm. But
this is like consistent practice every
day for 7 years. In the culture that we
live in, the reason that everyone
doesn't believe what meditation is
capable of
is because they don't understand the
time scale. Everyone's like, "Use this
app for 5 minutes. Do a different guided
meditation every day."
This is like telling someone, "Okay, I
want you to paint for 10 minutes today,
draw for 10 minutes tomorrow, go for a
swim 10 minutes the next day." If you
want to build something through
meditative practice, you have to do the
same practice
not necessarily every day, but basically
every day for years or decades
Got it.
in order to truly see the fruit of it.
So even even in my question of what are
you doing in that moment, it's like,
"What did I do for the prior 20 years?"
Is is almost the answer. So So so I
think no, I would say that that's not I
would say there's a distinction. So
there is 20 year That's not what he's
doing. 20 years is what his he has
become. So there's a difference between
playing an instrument and like playing a
guitar is different from becoming a
guitar. What he's been doing for 20
years is building a guitar. When he sits
with a person, he's playing the strings.
Does that make sense? Yeah. Okay?
Yeah, yeah. So here's what I would say
he does, which is what I do, which is
just the same but different. The more
empty you become, the more that you
remove your ego from the equation, then
you can attend fully to someone else.
Mhm. The analogy that I would use, this
is also like a meditative kind of thing,
was which is like the the story of two
cups. So this guy comes to to the
Buddha, and he's like, "I studied with a
bunch of teachers. I'm not enlightened
yet yet. Help me out." And Buddha's
like, "Cool. I'll help you out." So then
Buddha's like starts teaching him
things, but the guy's like, "But hold on
a second. I studied with this other guy,
and he said this." And then Buddha the
next day is like, "Okay, whatever. So
then do this." And he's like, "I studied
with this other guy he did this. And
then with the one day tells him, okay,
come back and then bring two cups. Bring
a cup of water and bring cup of milk.
He says, okay, now take the cup of
water, take the cup of milk, pour the
milk into the cup of water.
And the guy's like, what what do you
mean? And I'd encourage everybody to
pause the video right now and do this at
home. Take a cup of milk, take a cup of
water, pour the cup of milk into the cup
of water. Have them both full at the
beginning. What happens? The milk
overflows.
If you want to learn something, you need
to empty your mind first. If you want to
sit with someone, you have to empty
yourself. When Joe says he attends to
people,
the key thing there is that he is empty.
So, what the other person is enters him.
And then he attends to himself, but it's
not what he feels, he is an instrument.
He's like a radio wave uh he's like a
radio antenna picking up other things.
But the more that you have your own [__]
going on within yourself, when I sit
down so I can do this with random
strangers, I can never do it with my
wife.
The moment I sit with my wife
and she tells me how annoying I am, I'm
like, no, I'm not. I am adding something
to the equation.
This is also why it's easier to talk to
strangers and listen to strangers
because there's no ego, there's no
relationship, right? You can talk to a
stranger on a park bench, pour out your
heart and soul and it is easy to do
because you there's an emptiness to it.
There's no ego, there's no attachment.
So, I I would say that
he does it, I do it. I do it in a
slightly different way. So, I I operate
from a different place. My antenna is
tuned to a slightly different frequency.
wife does it in a different way, too.
Like if it's like if
if he's here on the spectrum, I'm here
on the spectrum, my wife is over here on
the spectrum. My wife will just
literally say almost nothing and
Yeah. and she'll just what if you just
put that 2 in behind yourself and
told just another different way. Well,
this is what I this is what's beautiful
about it is that I used to conceive of
and you can bucket charisma to there's
types of people who have really strong
visions and type of people who have high
convictions and types of people who are
funny.
But what I'm hearing is you know, if it
is this
divinely offered gift
it comes in as many different flavors as
there are people and there are things
that we seem to be tracking and that
there's an emptiness. There's a
listening. There's a thing but the way
that your wife shows up is going to be
with her own
flavor. So in a way and I this is what
I'm seeing in my own life. There was
always a seeking what's the right thing
to say now in the situation that I can
distribute in an online course and tell
everybody here's what to say to start
the conversation. Here's what to say 3
minutes into the conversation. Here's
how to get the date and that's helpful,
you know, to have the text message to
send the girl. It's necessary. I think
for me at a stage to like what do I text
what do I text what do I text? Give me
like hey, you know, I know this is crazy
but would you like to go out sometime?
Okay,
I'm okay. I can get through it.
Um
but this is where I'm super fascinated
as this spiritual thing connects with
charisma and the Greek word has just
fascinated me. I was like why did I pick
charisma? And there is something there
that was always there. What is charisma
on command? It can
can you open up to that
you that
uh
says the perfect thing that is you in
the moment instead of
the objectively perfect thing for the
moment. I don't know if that makes any
sense but that is okay. So given that
that there's all of these foundational
things that are established prior to
that moment.
In the moment for someone who you know,
hopefully is also doing these practices
maybe taking your course or your course
or going through it.
In the moment what is something that can
can done to begin this process just or
help it along a little bit to get to
that place of
emptiness or ability to
show up and listen in the way that is
most deeply effective or to say the
phrase that is most deeply effective or
even maybe my language is not even what
you would choose. I would give this one
as one of the
one of the practices that I notice works
really well
quickly and it works well because
when people taste it they want to keep
doing it. So part of a practice is
picking a practice that you actually
will keep doing or it's
and
and this practice has a lifespan like
most of the things that I would I would
suggest most of the things would have a
lifespan and it might be 10 20 years but
it has a lifespan and
um but what I notice a great way is that
to typically we have a negative
self-talker repetitive voice in the head
according to
I guess the Mayo Clinic it's like 50 to
60,000 thoughts a day or something like
that. Most of them are repetitive.
And people at some point notice them and
then at some point they want to get rid
of them.
And but the more they resist the more it
persists and so it doesn't actually
change. So a very cool practice that
starts emptying you out really quickly
is every day or every 3 days
pick a way you want to react to that
voice in the head that you've never
reacted that way before. So typically
though what happens is the voice says
something
and our response is
either yeah yeah you're right. That's
the charismatic part of you that you're
following or it's sometimes yeah you're
right but I'm not going to [__] do it
[__] Like yeah I'm going to I'm
still going to eat that chocolate cake
right? Those are the one of the
reactions that we have.
But you could have literally an infinite
kind
just thinking you could like clap and
have a ton of applause. You could have
applause
like a birthday party a surprise party.
You you could say yes you could you
could say you could say um
you could say wow I could really use you
to be a better boss." Mhm. Or you could
say, "No." Mhm. Or you could say, "I see
how scared you are and I'm right here
with you." Mhm. You can have literally a
hundred different responses.
What I'm noticing in me is that some of
those felt like oh, I want that one and
some of them didn't. So, even in just
listening to those options, I was like,
"Well, I like that last one the best."
Like I see
And so, but my my recommendation is
experiment
Mhm. for a while. Just get to know how
what what happens to that internal
self-talk that we consider to be us.
Mhm.
What happens when you react to it
differently?
And I find just the experimentation will
help you unfold the thing very, very
quickly. Mhm.
A lot quicker than than
for me, I I notice people unfold a lot
quicker than some early stages of
meditation even. Mhm. And it's but it's
really important and the critical point
is you're not trying to get rid of it.
And the critical point is that it's an
experimentation. You're learning about
it. You're you're in wonder about it.
Mhm. And if you can do that with the
internal self-talk, it is an incredibly
effective tool and I'm hoping
that what
you're about to tell me is that there's
a Sanskrit word for this practice. But,
I haven't seen any other
I haven't seen it before.
once again, Joe, I'm I'm impressed by
So, I could give you an hour-long
lecture about why that's a great
practice. Mhm. Ask away. But but the the
two things that I would say is first is
if that practice is hard for you, I'll
give you guys an introductory practice.
To cuz I I love it. I can't top that.
Yeah. All I can do is give you an
on-ramp onto that if that's hard. Mhm.
Um
and that is brush with your non-dominant
hand. Mhm.
So, what what I strongly recommend
people do
Totally. That would totally work. Oh,
that's so good. So so so it's so hard
with
the cognitions that we have. There
there's a whole I I it's so weird. So,
sometimes I'll do a a lecture like that
is like deep spirituality and it clicks
for people. So, I did this lecture on
vasanas, which are basically repetitive
mental habits.
Um so, great lecture that really like
popped. And and so, I'd say that the
problem with those is we're so engaged
with them, right? It's so challenging.
And I I I know why Joe recommends this
because if you learn it from Joe, he's
going to teach it in a way where you can
do it that you can't do on your own.
Like I I I get that, right? So, you give
them a certain amount of diksha or
initiation that allows them to do it,
but it's really hard because those
repetitive thoughts are often times the
ones that are the hardest to resist.
It's the hardest to do something new.
So, I just start with a little a touch
in neuroplasticity and practice the
skill of responding to things in
different ways. And the easiest way to
do that brush with your non-dominant
hand.
Right? You can only do it for a couple
of days. Joe will give you something
that'll work for 20 years. Do mine for
like 3 days. Then try Joe's. If you're
having trouble with it, you can go
straight to Joe's, go straight to Joe's.
Yeah. That's a really great. Yeah. I
love all of this. Okay. And part of the
reason that I didn't start down this
path is cuz when I looked out into the
world and it wasn't the same guys at the
time, but when I look at a Donald Trump
or an Andrew Tate, I do not imagine that
they are
doing this sort of thing and yet they
are incredibly influential,
uh powerful. People seem to follow them,
like them, trust them, uh polarizing
figures for sure.
What is going on? Like if this if this
takes you to the essence of charisma,
what is going on with
these seemingly charismatic individuals
that are that as far as I can tell have
not followed a path that is at all like
these ones. Um is that a pseudo
charisma? Is there something else going
on there? Is it What it How do you
understand it?
Yeah. The What I notice is this is a
really
challenging topic because it's so we're
using two people who are very divisive.
And show. So, to some degree
guy in your office who doesn't appear to
do this or something.
Um
So, there's a couple things that I would
say is that
um
without judgment on
developmental scale or anything like
that.
Um
My daughters are 3 and 1/2 years apart.
What I notice is that's who kids adore.
Mhm. It's like they listen to other kids
that are just slightly older than more
than
My whole life I have been following
reluctantly
questioning
the authorities that are just have a
little more understanding than I have at
this moment and I'm I'm following that.
So, I think that there's
a natural
One part is I think there's a natural
peace to that. Um the other thing that's
interesting is that people really want
to buy the bridge, you know? They really
want to buy the We all really want to
buy the bridge until we don't. So,
there's something natural in us in the
evolutionary path to
have somebody who has the answer. Has
somebody who feels assured, who feels
conviction. And we want that. If you
look at
like whether it's our rock stars or our
politicians, it's like there's something
in us that wants to feel safe and if we
follow somebody who looks like they're
assured and and in their minds they are.
I mean, empathetically we they are
convicted.
Yeah, there's a we're like tuning in to
like oh, they they believe this through
and through.
do. Yeah. That is a like and and if they
don't, the third time they say it, they
will. And so, so there's like this part
of us that it's like oh, cool. There's
some conviction that I don't Now I don't
have to actually take responsibility
Mhm. for myself. And then I think
there's something really
that that that's another part that makes
it that we
And so some of it is this very natural
thing that we want I think the other
piece that's occurring is that
as a society like we talked about
like as a society we want homeostasis we
want balance as well and so what I
notice is that
when any side gets righteous
Mhm.
when there's an if there's no naysayer
in the room eventually the naysayer
comes up if any side gets righteous
there's the other part of it
Yeah. And so
but to me the more
the the the the more
um
great question the the question that is
more productive the more productive
question is
when you're faced with somebody like
that Mhm. what's what's how can they be
a an an avenue to your freedom
to to your unwinding to your
and
can you see their point of view can you
understand the value that they provide
can you not see their point can you see
outside of their point of view can you
not see the can you use them as a way to
dissolve your ego
assuming there's an ego but right that
that you that can you use that person
as a way to dissolve and and it was
funny you said earlier this great
thought of you know there's a joke in
your community about being a guru and I
if anybody says calls me a guru often
times what I'll say is like I'm yeah I'm
just like a guru I'm just the next
iteration where I want all the power to
be in your hands not in mine Wow.
It's a it's a good one right
um Love it.
but the but it's the
but it's that same thing it's like it if
if that person has you pissed off
or enraptured or
or enraptured they got you Yeah yeah.
you right that you're not you're not
actually in yourself anymore and you're
and you there's so much to learn about
your trigger, about how they're your
projection or all that stuff that can
get to your own freedom Mhm. instead of
like you know, what makes them that.
It's interesting cuz the opposition to
Trump and the opposition to Andrew Tate
is arguably the thing that has fueled
Absolutely.
the the and and that same thing is
occurring internally, which is when you
see someone who is
so certain, so this, so that and you
know, no, they're not and instead of
like what what breaks inside of me when
I or what hurts or what when I come into
contact with that. That's an interesting
practice.
Yeah. And and that's the and and we all
want to be able to fall
yes, take care of me and we all want to
resist it. It's like and all of that's
in ourselves and it's all happening in
ourselves.
If you're really bothered by Donald
Trump, I guarantee you you have a voice
in your head that sounds a lot like
Donald Trump.
It just yeah, this is how yeah, no,
yeah, interesting. Yeah. And if you
right? So so anyways, that that's that's
the place where I think that there's
freedom rather than to
It's It's the I mean I'm I like the
union psychoanalysis, but so for me I'm
conceiving like the return of the
repressed, the externalization of the
shadow in me, which is when I look at
it, it's this repressed power drive.
This unashamed I want, I take, I that is
out there and I am good with that and I
have no issue and then I look I mean I
don't know you don't want to go into it,
but I look at the left or the Democrats,
it's there's this
hidden power drive, you know, that is
not claimed in the same way.
Interesting. Yeah, I've
working with CEOs a lot, really powerful
CEOs, what I notice is if they
um
fully are like, I want power and this is
power and da da da da da, they are
incredibly dangerous people. If they are
fully I don't want power, I'm not the
most powerful there, incredibly
dangerous people.
me. That was me. Not that I was hurting
anyone, but yeah.
It is to It is like to acknowledge the
power that you have, to to to not run
away from your narcissism, to in to to
love all of that as well. Both
disintegrates it and also just on an
actionable level makes you far safer.
Mhm. And it's the rejection of both and
and the or the grasping of both that
makes you dangerous and if you have a
lot lot of power.
Yeah. Did you Anything that comes up for
you around that? Yeah, so I you know, I
I I love Joe's answer and I'm going to
give a completely different one. So so I
I think you know, if we go back to like
the mechanism of okay, there's the
sleazy charisma, there's the authentic
charisma. I think what a lot of people
will kind of potentially jump to is like
oh, they have the sleazy charisma. Mhm.
I think this is where the model Yeah.
Yeah, that's not true.
It's not true. I agree. So and and
that's like their own judgment, right?
So I I I think what they really speak to
is how much of a dyad charisma is. Mhm.
So why are they the ones that are
popular? There's a thousand people who
are saying a thousand things. They're
the ones who have floated to the top.
For someone to be charismatic in that
way, they must have an audience. Mhm. So
if you want to understand why they are
charismatic, you must look to the
audience because they're the ones that
are watching them. Mhm. Yep. So here is
the harsh truth that I think not many
people are willing to accept.
So if you're a man in the world today
and
something doesn't go your way, no one is
there to help you.
So speaking of Democrats, I'm not saying
this is right or wrong. I'm just making
an observation. So if you look at the
during the presidential election, if you
look at the Democratic website for the
the the people they support and the
mission they support, they support
minorities, they support people of
different sexual things
orientations, immigrants. Like I'm I'm
that's right or wrong. And then at the
very end they say women. Mhm.
They literally listed a bunch of people,
chose a gender,
and did not pick men. Mhm.
Intentionally.
Right? So so if you're a man today and
you struggle, the most common thing you
hear is you're privileged, you don't
have a right to complain, especially if
you're Oh my god, like y'all are the
worst. Y'all are white men. At least I'm
a minority or my skin is brown, right?
I'm part of the oppressed. Mhm.
And and so what literally like you have
people but like men have the highest
suicide rates and they're climbing.
I you know, I I love it. I had a patient
I used to work a a a lot with people in
finance.
And I had a patient who had a kid and
she wanted to go back into investment
banking.
And the bank has a program for mothers
who have left
to raise their kids because like women
we as a society
should support
women who make choices. And if they make
choices and they want to make career
changes or if they're having difficulty,
we should have like equality of like
board representation between men and
women. We should help women get into
college. We should have women-only
scholarships. And I'm not saying these
things are bad. I'm just saying this is
the way society is right now.
There are plenty of women-only
scholarships, very few male-only
scholarships, but 60% of people in
college are women.
So if you look at the experience of men,
they don't get help from anybody.
If a man has difficulty with their
emotions, no woman wants to take
responsibility. And fair enough, right?
They say like, "It's not my job to baby
this man." That's the work that I do to
a certain degree, you do to a certain
degree, you do. And I think it's in that
order. I think maybe I have the biggest
babies, but who knows, right?
And and so like this is the like
literally the experience of men. You can
look at all kinds of metrics. so what I
just look at suicide. And a few years
ago, I asked myself a question, "If men
have it so easy, why are they killing
themselves at four times the rate of
women? Like, why do these men" and I've
had men in my office who are privileged,
6'4, rich, white men who want to kill
themselves.
You know, like have fantasies of tying a
noose around their neck,
tying the other part of the noose to a
tree, getting in a car, and slamming on
the gas pedal. Mhm.
So, like, what is going on? Like like
are they privileged? Yes.
And there's more to the story.
Do they have advantages? Yes. And
there's more to the story. But we live
in a society that does not accept that.
So, the weird thing is everyone thinks
that Andrew Tate is super toxic. He's
the most validating voice.
He's the most emotionally validating for
voice that I've heard talking to men.
Donald Trump, same thing for his
audience. Yeah. Absolutely, right? So,
everyone says, "Your audience, my
audience, not sure about you."
Right? So, like
our audience, Charlie, is I mean, this
isn't true really, but like it's losers,
right? There are a lot of
"losers" in our audience. So, what we
realize is there are a lot of young
professionals. The average age in our
audience is now like 32. It's like 30 to
35% women. So, I'm sort of making a
characterization that's not really
accurate. But there are a lot of people
dudes out there who are struggling, feel
like losers,
trying to fix being a loser.
And what does the world tell them? The
world tells them, "You've got a bunch of
advantages. You're fine. You should And
if you're not fine, you should be fine
because you're a privileged man."
There's one person who tells them they
are [__] and that person is Andrew
Tate. Andrew Tate says, "You are [__]
Let me help you
from beta You're a piece of [__]
I I'm going to validate your existence."
and a reality placing.
like you're right. Yeah.
You're I'm not The world The world is
unfair. There are 1% of men who get
everything and 99% you are a [__]
loser. Here's how to change. Versus
people are like, "That's not true. Love
yourself. Have Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah,
yeah." Exactly.
Exactly. The other thing about their
character
their charisma is in both of the cases
that you mentioned is that they they're
really not self-conscious. Yeah, deeply.
Yeah. Right. They're really not
self-conscious. Mhm. They
One of them hugged a flag. Mhm. You
know, like that's like performance art
and lack of self-consciousness. That's
like an amazing lack of
self-consciousness. And And I think that
all of us want that.
Mhm. All of us want that lack of
self-consciousness on on top of we might
not want it in that particular way, but
we all want that on some level. And it's
it's an interesting thing cuz I was
looking at
um
who won the election
over the like since Jimmy Carter
and I was just watching different
different of them speaking. It's like,
"Wow, it's kind of like almost the
person who has less self-consciousness
wins." It's pretty It's a It's a really
good indicator.
Mhm. The less self-conscious, the more
they're likely to win. Mhm. They don't
have to be smart. They don't have to
even be articulate. It's just like a
lack of
I'm going to be me. Which is less
internal division. Correct.
It's greater sense of internal, yeah.
Less internal division. Mhm.
In that particular aspect.
Yes. Yes.
Right? Cuz like I do not think that they
go home and are not divided internally,
but you know, I could be I I think they
both have a vision. Yes. Right? And I
think they're both articulate. Mhm. Like
I mean, people will say like Trump
stumbles around with his words and stuff
like that, but he's able to speak. So,
what
I mean, he'll say all kinds of things,
but there are a couple of statements
that will really resonate with the dyad.
Mhm. And then the other really
interesting like
metaphoric thing here is we've been
talking about, you You if there's
something bad
and you try to make it go away,
it just comes back stronger.
Mhm. That's right. And these two people
have one really interesting thing. The
harder people try to take them down,
Mhm. the stronger they become.
Right? And so there's something going on
here where that's just not the energy.
They they thrive off of it.
Right? That cuz what what it does is it
galvanizes their supporters. It creates
more of an us versus them kind of
mentality. Mhm. You know, and I and I
and I think I I know I mean so
we talked with Sneako a while ago. And I
I don't know if it was you or someone on
your on your channel. I I did the video,
yeah. And and so I think like people
will sometimes blame us for talking to
platforming toxic dudes.
My conversations with like Sneako and
Aiden Ross and some of these like toxic
people are some of my most favorite
conversations.
I know this is going to get me a lot of
flak, but I think there's like they're
good dudes.
I think the way I think your handling of
it is exactly the antidote and is so
important and is so inclusive and does
not leave anyone behind. I I love
watching those conversations.
Right right so so so that that like oh
like you shouldn't talk to bad people,
then like what do you And I'm not I'm
not saying
you shouldn't talk Some people say you
shouldn't talk to bad people.
And then I'm like, well then what should
you do? Right? And then people will say
you should cancel them, you should
destroy them. And like that's fine. I'm
not saying that that's wrong. It's not
my place to say like if you want to
annihilate whatever, like go for it.
That's not what I know how to do. Mhm.
That's not my gift to the world. That's
not the methodology that I've seen
works.
And so I I I I think these are people
that we should be I completely agree
with you what Joe is saying about these
people serve a karmic purpose of like
awakening. Mhm. Like if you really have
problems with these people, look within
yourself first. Mhm.
Right? And and see what's your issue.
What are you really angry about?
How can you not understand?
Right? So then you're you're like you're
like I don't understand how people like
even within my family like
there's a huge generational divide
between like Democrats and Republicans
and we're like all like in the same
general household, but
and and people like I don't understand.
And people say that reflexively.
Right? Like I don't understand how
someone could follow Andrew Tate or vote
for Donald Trump. Then the first [__]
thing you should do is understand.
Don't judge.
Try to really figure out because clearly
they are doing something that matters a
lot to a lot of people.
And if you ever want to change this
dynamic
good diagnosis precedes good treatment.
It starts with understanding. Then you
can figure out what to do. Trying to
take them down may work, may not work. I
have no idea.
But I think that there's something
really like powerful going on
and I think that like kind of like what
Joe is saying, I know it sounds kind of
weird, but like
whether this is good or bad depends on
what we do with it.
Mhm.
Yeah, absolutely.
I think that it's an interesting
it's an interesting thought process,
right? If you're if you
are in a place that is harmful to you
and you are seeking help
you're typically not seeking judgment.
You're not seeking egoic judgment.
We know inherently that if somebody can
show up with us as a human being and be
with us as a human being that that's
probably one of the most
effective ways for us to heal.
And
the the thought process that I love
around this is imagine that you go onto
an island
and you have all the food and water that
you could ever use in this island and
you're there with 12 people,
and those 12 people all happen to be
saints.
And saints,
they draw boundaries, they they they
take care of themselves, but they
conditionally love you. They love you
unconditionally.
They don't accept everything you do, but
they unconditionally love you. And now
imagine you're stuck on that island for
a decade.
Like, what happens? Who are you when you
walk off that island? So, we like know
this that we
Yeah, we don't need anyone to coach us
or train us. We just Yeah, yeah.
thing. And yet, when we see something
out in the world that we don't like,
the very last thing we think to do is
behave like a saint.
Yeah. Beautiful.
Would love to continue, and I want to
get you fed. So, thank you both for
sitting down with me today.
No food for you.
Um
amazing chatting with both of you guys
today.
Yeah, it was an absolute privilege.
Oh my gosh. Yeah.